if Milwaukee goes Owen for losses
tonight to st. Louis and then gets swept
somehow at home by Detroit and if
Colorado goes 4 and 1 with their two
games against Philadelphia and three
games at home against Washington and if
st. Louis sweeps out beating Milwaukee
tonight and sweeps the Cubs which would
be part of the Cubs going on five to
finish the season that would be a six
way tie in the National League at 91 and
71 I know it's kind of dumb and Dumberer
you're saying there's a chance but there
is what in the world would happen then
MLB networks and the Athletics Jason
stark here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Jason
rich I'm good Rudy for chaos there's
always right what that's I mean that's
not out of the realm right I mean that's
not totally crazy obviously the Cubs
having to lose out they've already lost
to know that would be a seven game
losing streak for them to finish out the
season I would say it's all unlikely but
you know one of these years something
like this has to happen
we've never even had a three-way tie
since they went to the division system
so one of these years were going to have
this madness and you know at certain
that scenario that you just described
would be a problem you know why because
Major League Baseball does not have a
six-way tie brace for a five-way tie
breaker don't have one well they'd have
to figure out what head-to-head would
kick people out until they get to a
manageable number and then play certain
minutes of elimination games right and
would not I mean I'm assuming because of
what you're describing you know you'd
have ties for two divisions so you would
have to play off for the divisions and
so that means you know the Dodgers and
Rockies would have to pay play a
head-to-head then there is a three-way
tie breaker formula to decide how a you
know a division tie that I'm assuming
would have to go into effect for Cubs
Brewers and Cardinals oh that would take
a couple of days that would you
once the smoke cleared then you'd have
the wild card thing settled got it and
then the Yankees in the A's would played
for for all some marbles and Richmond
therefore the American League might have
to play to have them play every night to
the national you got it figured out what
is what is going through the minds in
Boston right now I know Houston just
wrapped up the AL West they have a
hundred win seasons back-to-back for the
first time in their franchise's history
but what's going through the minds of a
Red Sox team that has absolutely
surprised by how how successful they
have been all year long and it looks
like them they're gonna have to play a
five-game series against either the A's
or their their hated rivals from New
York City Jason well the whole a all
half of the draw is going to be epic
epic you'll have 300 Win teams and you
know potentially or if the Yankees don't
get any has a team with the best record
in baseball since the middle of June and
the Red Sox are the best team they've
earned that you better know anyone wants
to twice you they're surrounded by
people who has figured out everything
that could possibly go wrong
Chris Sale isn't ready he loses Game one
and they've got to turn to David prices
never want to postseason start if Chris
Sale loses Game one it's panic in the
streets
throughout New England I don't think
there's any doubt about that but they're
the best team are they the favorite I
don't know but they're the best team and
when it comes down to it they JD
Martinez and the in the crucible of the
playoffs in Boston we'll see how that
all goes down and and obviously
Houston's been there and done that
do you believe Boston is the best team
though you called epic are they are they
when you if you had to put your marker
on somebody who do you put it on Jason
stark I think that the most complete
team if healthy would be the Astros and
yet I've had people tell me that the
winner of Astros Indians the series I'll
be covering is going to go win the World
Series because the innings are
incredibly dangerous and their top three
offense in the game with with a great
rotation and you know those questions
about whether their bullpen has got
itself straightened out but
you know October affords a lot more rest
in the regular season and that plays
into their hands they've got a great
manager it's I don't know anybody who's
got a good feel for who's gonna win
especially over in the American League
and internationally who is the best team
I mean if you had to put your marker on
a team in the NL out of all these teams
that has gone out there I the Dodgers
are the deepest team I had a game the
other day where they had five guys in
their bench who did 20 homers this year
it's just their bench is better than
some team's lineups and you know depth
helps you survive the season whether
depth helps you win the World Series is
a whole nother story but I think if you
look at the entire National League field
there's so many flaws in every team the
Dodgers had the fewest flaws so I would
pick them but then am i picking a
Dodgers Astros World Series rematch that
never happens I know well you first they
got to get there it just seems that they
just can't get on track every single
time you think they're in and then
they're rolling like last year
something happens right and you know
what I am Telling my Dodger friends
around here and in its kind of heresy
form I'm like either Seager is gonna
have to learn another position or
Turner's gone because I don't think
they're letting Manny Machado walk out
of here certainly if they make the
playoffs and see what this young man can
do he is dynamite what do you think I
actually don't think that Manny winds up
back in LA really things possible but
Justin Turner is so important to that
team
I know his figures so important to that
team the left side of their infield is
probably the most settled part of their
team unless Corey Seager's got long term
issues and he's not going to be able to
throw the ball across the diamond that
would change everything you know one of
the Dodgers people said to me after they
made that trade when I asked about this
very thing we don't do this you know we
don't we don't do the eight-year 10-year
contract at
two hundred three hundred four hundred
million dollars and I really think that
Manny Machado is going to wind up with
the team that puts the biggest pile of
money in front of them I I just don't
think that's going to be the Dodgers
look he's so good man I mean like I
don't know how you let somebody that
good walk certainly if they make the
playoffs I think he's gonna have an
incredible October and if he's a
difference maker for them when it all
online did you you've seen the woods
with the Dodgers the last few years even
last year in the in the playoffs getting
to Game seventh just getting scratching
out runs sometimes for them was so
difficult
III don't know I I'm four again you're
the insider obviously with the the
athletic and MLB Network it just strikes
me that that would be tough to let him
walk if he has an incredible October all
right I I just think it's a different
climate it's a different front office
and back in the days of the last Manny
all right you know after Manny Ramirez
did what he did in 2008 there was just
so much sentiment and so much emotion
that they had to bring him back I don't
think this front office makes emotional
decisions and so if if Manny Machado is
to return it's a baseball decision it's
a financial decision it would be really
contingent on how many years and dollars
the investment would have to be it this
is I don't want to say they're
cold-blooded but they're not going to
get caught up in the sentiment even if
the sentiment follows them one of the
World Series
Jason stark MLB Network here on the Rich
Eisen show just whip through it your
your AL MVP saw young and same for the
National League what do you have years
where there's almost nothing that's cut
and dry cut and dried let me do it al
first sir
I think Mookie Betts is the AL MVP
barely over Mike Trout the site young
debate is fascinating because means
Justin Verlander's number
with incredible volume with a lot more
volume a hundred and thirty four more
hitters and Blake smell like Snell makes
a fascinating debate but I think that
Blake Snell is going to win and should
win and you know you know the only two
starting pitchers in the DEA chera who
had a lower er a than he has and he had
one nine Oh Pedro Martinez and Ron
Guidry of her during the day and that's
gonna that sways me I've heard of them
NL Jacob degrom should win the Sion wins
aside and I maghen izing over NL MVP I
have a column that it's posting athletic
today yeah which I pick Javy Baez but
admit that I'm a voter I could still
change my mind
depending on what happens is week Yelich
would it be him he's so good but Baez or
Yelich is what I'm down to and Kristen
Yelich has made an incredible case and
even an incredible case this week the
final week of the season narrative can
sway this vote I don't think there's any
question I would guess Kristy else is
going to win just hard to make the point
that we only think of it Cubs as a
star-studded team but in truth the
Brewers position players this year had
been much better than the cups and the
Cubs have needed everything that Javy
Baez has done offensively defensively on
the bases the energy jolt every night it
but it's really a fun debate no I know I
mean in terms of I agree with you last
week should matter I mean certainly is
if divisions on the line and playoffs
are on the line Yelich with a bases
clearing triple in st. Louis okay yeah
in st. Louis that is that when when he
landed on third last night I'm like
that's the definition of value right
there that is that was a most valuable
hit for the Brewers and I know you can't
boil it down to one at-bat but when you
were boiling it down a push coming to
shove
maybe that's it yeah hey I agree I got
voted on this stuff many times and you
know the last impression is a powerful
impression that isn't right it isn't
fair I'm not sure why it is it's human
nature and there's so much on the line
this week you know the Cubs have led the
Brewers and had the best record in the
league since the all-star break and if
the Brewers overtake them in the final
week and Christian Yelich has this kind
of week and this kind of second half
he's going to win and he would deserve
to win well a little bit of a preview of
what we're gonna see on the athletic
later on Jason thanks for joining us
here really appreciate it
Oh a dredge tank you bet it you bet at
Jason St with a why by the way for Jason
on Twitter a Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience